the village of schulte has become a
symbol of germany's suffering
and today the chancellor came here
angela merkel leader of europe's richest
nation
confronted by the might of natural
disaster
merkel was in america when the floods
hit but this was a very visible
visit to a devastated area a chance to
connect with people who are frightened
and bewildered
her next stop another town just down the
road
and so angela merkel arrives here in
adenauer and what the people of
this town what the people of germany
want isn't just
sympathy and empathy they want their
chancellor to tell them
how this rich sophisticated nation can
recover
what they got was a promise that a plan
was imminent
i've come here today to symbolize that
we are standing together in solidarity
we will fix it all one step at a time we
have to act
fast i am promising you the government
will issue a programme
next week so we can work towards a rapid
recovery
today the sun was out no floods here but
an audience in shirt sleeves
a reminder of nature's capricious
ferocity
my question to you chancellor merkel is
what
is your message to the world now after
this disaster that we've all watched
about the danger of climate change
what we invest into climate change is
expensive but the impact of climate
change costs even more
one flooding disaster on its own is not
climate change
the increased frequency of them is we
must make big changes
the images of these floods are
extraordinary
pitched against this power it's little
wonder that europe's death toll has been
so
horribly high in the town of ramagan
they're collecting donations for those
whose homes and lives have been battered
the mayor insisted that lessons must be
learned from this disaster
we need to help those people who lost
everything we need to have money money
money
billions of euros we need i'm quite sure
and then we need to really
um stand to what we said in paris
for the paris agreement on climate
change down the road a shelter for those
left homeless we meet tyre
she's 69 years old and has been here
since thursday night
she's scared of the flooding she doesn't
want to go home
[Music]
we meet she was offered a room to use
until the water subside
like so many germans tire is walking
into an uncertain future adam parsons
sky news western germany